Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am chest checking in on you late Wednesday night while my daughter sleeps
in the next F and room.
Ma,
I got to keep quiet on this one.
I got to keep it down.
Keep it down.
I turned up the volume so I can whisper a little bit here.
Right.
I gotta knock this fucker out.
I got a table read for episode eight of Season Three,
eight of 10,
where 80% of the way there for you mathletes out there.
Very excited.
Starting to see the light at the end of the tunnel before the horrific editing
process begins.
And uh,
you know,
we'll just be working for another year and uh,
get everything all locked and I'll have maybe three days off and then we'll
start all over again.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp Oh,
Ludo too.
Um,
what's going on?
How are you?
I,
yeah,
how's your week going?
Is that all right?
I'm actually a,
if I do the table read,
um,
I got a bright,
some more shit and then late night I'm going to be traveling up to Toronto where
I'm doing three shows that the Sony Fuck and sat up Toronto,
one of my favorite cities.
You know,
I like,
I like a nice small city,
you know,
everybody knows everybody's name.
That's what I love about Toronto.
You know what I mean?
It's not this fucking monstrosity with a ton of traffic.
Everybody's down to Earth.
I actually really like,
you know,
it's the biggest God damn city,
basically for,
uh,
people in the United States.
All right.
Who never look up when they're walking around so they never see Canada.
Right.
He'd dumb like me were north to you is looking up cause you can't fucking,
you have no spatial relation to how you stand on this planet.
Um,
it was the capital of Canada,
but Toronto is,
is like,
it's kind of like how Albany is like the capital of New York,
but it's all about New York City.
Albany is the capital of New York state,
I should say it.
Sure.
They have the egg,
you know,
they have a fuck in minor league hockey team.
There's a lot to like an Albany got some beautiful theaters.
You know what I mean?
They got that fucking,
we used to build shit here before it all left,
you know,
for 30 years.
And now we're coming back around with a little tech savvy horse shit,
like all these fucking rust belt cities.
Not Saying Albany was in the rust belt,
but I'll look it up,
look up,
look up what's going on in Pittsburgh.
The revitalization of the downtown area is all these fucking nerds who make
websites and uh,
robots and you know,
synthetic heroin,
whatever the fuck it is these nerds do for these sociopaths,
for these fucking sociopath.
That's how it works.
Nerds.
I saw that.
My Act nerds make fucking sociopath dreams come true.
That's what the fuck they do.
Okay.
Sociopath's are crazy enough to think shit,
but they need a nerd to actually make it a fucking reality.
And nerds do not have the background to backbone,
I should say.
They don't have the backbone to tell fucking sociopath's.
You know what,
Dude,
I know I could figure out how to do that,
but I'm not going to make that.
They won't do it.
And they're all sitting around making robots that they can fuck right now to get
rid of that guilt.
Okay.
And we're taking,
callers were taking,
callers will read them live.
Um,
Toronto.
What's it doing to Rob Toronto?
Sorry,
just had some fucking corn checks.
Um,
by the way,
I haven't been working out cause my cap was fucked up and I'm,
I'm still dropping weight just by not boozing and eating like a fucking angel.
Do you know what I have every fucking night?
Like probably four out of seven nights a week at this premade to bully salad
that has this little,
I don't know if it's Coos,
coos,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Tomatoes and onions in it.
And then I put a little fucking chicken in there and I just eat that shit.
Like the fuel that it is,
I just shovel it into my mouth to stop the,
the hunger feeling.
And that's around five 30 at six.
And then I don't do anything and if I get a little extra hug,
it did it set tonight,
you know,
burned a little calories and every once in a while I'll come home.
I just have a fucking bowl of cereal and then that's it.
I have to tell you,
dude,
I got to tell you,
I got on the scale today,
old fucking Billy Alabaster freckled fat tits was down to 175 pounds.
I was up to a buck 85 I was a buck 90 last summer,
so I'm down to one 75 my fighting weight is one 72 I got this acting Gig and two
fucking weeks and I've been unable to work out by fucking rotator cuff is all
fucked up again.
I was imitating this blowup doll on stage and I stuck my fucking arm out and it
started burning again.
It's like,
really?
I'm a,
I'm a God damn man.
I have to,
you know what I have to do.
I have to go to a physical therapist and I have to,
I have to start being in better patient.
Like,
you know when they tell me to do some shit,
I need to go fucking do the shit.
That's what the fuck I need to do to finally get past the shit cause I haven't
worked out.
You know,
I used to be pulled up guy.
I got a bet with Paul Versey that when I'm 70 years old and still be able to do
10 pull ups,
I won't even be able to do that when I turned 50 the way this is fucking going.
I'm what I'm trying to say here,
people is I'm falling apart and I know there's a lot of benefits out there.
Okay.
From,
you know,
people's who's fucking,
heads where fuse together with their brother,
whatever.
Whatever your fucking causes.
All right.
What about broken down middle aged,
white male heterosexuals.
What about that?
What of all about all of us.
Okay.
After enjoying half a century of privilege,
you know what about us with our sore calf and our sore right shoulder.
What about that?
How people,
you know,
I want to know how much you care.
I just want to turn a fucking corner with this goddamn thing.
Can't do it.
I haven't been able to do it.
I mean,
they're the rotator cuffs at a tough,
you know,
they gay kind of fucking lingo.
I know,
I know.
I'm living with it.
Um,
so my name's,
I've been talking to some people recently and you know,
I've always just joked around about pharmaceutical companies.
I keep hearing this rumor that they started the,
Oh,
this fucking heroin epidemic and everything and they just found out,
you know,
someone from like the town I grew up in 23 years old,
just fucking died of a heroin overdose.
I grew up in fucking Mayberry.
And uh,
someone was talking about like basically all these fucking things,
oxy,
Percocet,
all of that shit.
It has the exact same fucking addictive qualities,
chemical makeup,
all of that shit is heroin.
It's just like a synthetic heroin and a difference between an opiate in an
opioid and opiate is natural.
Like those poppy fucking things you always see in those chuck Norris movies,
right?
And then,
uh,
the poppy seeds there and then in a opiate is just like manufactured nerds.
Nerds,
you fucking go into the doctor like me,
I fucked up my calf.
This fucking guy goes,
all right and we'll give you a painkiller and I'm going to give you an anti
inflammatory.
So I go to the fucking pharmaceutical.
Pharmacists are fucking hilarious.
The fact that they get to dress up like their doctors is one of the funniest
fucking things.
It's like,
what are you doing in there?
It's like you're,
you're basically working the Starbucks of the medical field,
you know?
Well,
what do you do?
What the fuck are you doing back?
You should get me a cup of coffee with my fucking pills.
They always act like they're so God damn,
you know,
just under the gun where you're back to,
you count an aspirin.
I get,
you know what?
Enough way,
you know what the fucking worst thing is,
is when somebody like,
it's like running.
There's nothing.
People think cops are bad.
The worst thing you want to have fucking attitude.
Get a rent a cop.
Cars in the,
in the,
in the back of his head,
he knows he's not a real cops and now he's got something to prove.
A cop's a cop,
you know what I mean?
So He's,
he knows he's,
you know,
he's got a gun and he's got a fucking license to kill him.
I'll stick this right in the back of your fucking mouth and I'll pull the
trigger and go down and go get a sandwich and I even think about it.
Right?
Fuck Rental Cup.
Where does he get maybe as a taser?
It got a little fucking stick.
So he's got to be some cut and run around taking some little fucking kid's
skateboard away,
right?
Th they,
they,
they dabble in that shit.
So always that type of shit,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
if you're going to get it threesome right,
there's always the beautiful girl.
And then the other one who's fucking annoying,
who's got to start running a Yap.
Even if she is beautiful,
she knows she's not as good looking as the other one.
That brings up the insecurity and then she won't shut the fuck up.
She tries to be funny or something like that.
A stupid sloppy tits hanging out.
It's like,
what are you doing?
I don't care how fucking ugly you are.
You don't think I'm going to work my way through you to get to her to shut up.
I don't know what the fuck this has to do with pharmaceutical companies.
Okay.
But I know when I went to this pharmacy with my calf problem,
all right,
I was supposed to get,
he said a painkiller.
I'm like,
well,
I'm not fucking with those.
I'm going to fucking with those.
I'm not getting heroin in a fucking synthetic form and start tailoring I,
but look how I handled beaus people,
or I should say,
look how Booz handled me.
Okay.
It was like triple G.
Walk it down Alvarez the other day.
That's what fucking booze does to me.
Backing up the whole fucking fight.
Maybe once a while I plant and I fucking throw a couple combinations.
You know what the bottle does?
It eats it up.
Hey,
d eight sit up.
Right?
But my wife's sitting there,
gone here,
not an alcoholic has be winning.
One 18,
one 10 figure that one out.
So I fucking go in
to a CVS,
right?
Which is a great place.
If you need to buy somebody a card,
you know,
get a gallon of root beer and get some fucking heroin,
right?
Maybe some shit and fucking,
I don't know,
shaving cream or some shit.
Right?
So
the fucking,
you know,
rent a fucking Dr. Guy behind there.
He fucking,
you know,
it's,
it's going to be like 20 minutes.
So I'm going gonna be like 20 minutes.
All right?
Okay.
Whatever.
I get it.
There's a lot of different colored pills back there.
You got to look at your pill chart.
See which color the blue ones are for boys.
And the red ones are for old people.
Whatever that sciences.
Yeah,
they're,
they're back there acting like they make the pills.
I need to shut the fuck up about pharmacists.
I got to read up on him here.
Farmers.
Let me finish telling this story.
Um,
so the guy finally comes back,
right?
I'm standing by and all these cute fucking old people,
you know what I mean?
For fucking people with all that God damn pills for the ailments and shit.
Um,
and uh,
he gives me two vials and I go,
okay,
what's this one?
He goes,
those are the paint painkillers.
And I'm like,
all right,
well,
I'm not messing with that.
And I,
and I go,
what are these?
And he goes,
those,
uh,
those are more pain pills.
Okay.
And I'm like,
well what about the antiinflammatory?
He goes,
oh,
it's,
it's in these painkillers.
And it's just like,
oh,
I don't want that.
I just want the antiinflammatory.
But you know what it is,
is he's fucking drug companies.
They're drug dealers.
So they get,
they want to get me hooked.
So you want the antiinflammatory,
you got to do a little fucking synthetic heroin was with it.
Okay.
Now base in all of this on my own fucking paranoia and like two conversations
had over the last 48 hours.
Okay?
And now I'm in my fucking house,
like in that movie,
Beautiful Mind.
I'm taking fucking,
I'm cutting out headlines from papers that I don't read and up.
I'm blinking it all together and presenting it as fact to you.
Okay.
Pharmacists,
what do they do?
Okay.
Alright.
They advise physicians and other health practitioners on the selections,
dosage interactions and side effects of medication.
They also plan and monitor drug programs or regiments.
Pharmacist Council hospitalized patients on the use of drugs and on their use at
home when the patients are discharged.
Yeah,
you made it the back of the CVS.
Okay.
Take two of these twice a day.
Take one on the third day and then flush the rest of it,
right?
MMM.
Pharmacists
level of edging toot.
Everything just pops up like I wrote what and then it immediately popped up.
Do they do,
I said level and immediately of education immediately popped up.
Doctoral or professional degree.
All right.
Here's what you got to do.
There's no way this is,
no,
no.
This can't be more than a two year fucking program.
Okay.
Here you go.
Here's a video on how to be a fucking pharmacist.
It's a fucking cartoon character in a pharmacist and a pharmacy.
Educational requirements in career center.
Becoming a pharmacist requires a significant amount of formal education.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Learn about education,
job duties,
and trained to see if this is the right career for you.
Okay.
Find the perfect school k doctor of pharmacy degree fields.
Non-Specified two years of undergraduate study.
I got four is required to apply for pharmacy school.
Okay.
Licensed required in all states.
I got one of those to sell health insurance.
That's not impressive.
You take a test and then your licensed experienced clerkship residency's
fellowships.
This is bullshit.
Key skills,
attention to detail.
Oh,
did I say for Percocet?
I meant one.
Uh,
an extensive knowledge of drugs and interactions.
Okay,
there you go.
I'll give you that one.
Research communication,
interpersonal customer service skills.
Okay.
Job Outlook.
3% growth.
Medium annual salary.
$121,500 given up for the pharmacist.
Jesus.
No.
One of their lab coats is so God damn clean off the back.
They're raking in the fucking money.
I'll tell you,
if you start selling some of those drugs on the side to the people,
you get addictive in the front.
Okay.
You know,
just saying you get those fake tits,
they're sweeter,
died,
amazing weight.
This week I actually got to a,
I got to fucking play drums for about two and a half hours with a tremendous
musician who was just like,
hey man,
do you want to fucking jam?
And I was like,
yeah man,
I want a jam.
And I didn't even know what that meant.
I thought it was going to go down there and just be like,
Hey,
do you know highway to hell?
That's what I thought it was going to be.
I showed up.
This guy was doing that,
you know that Reggie Watts thing where yeah,
we fucking builds up,
he'll make like drum sounds and then I'll make guitar songs and then whatever
and whatever,
whatever.
And then he starts fucking singing over it,
right.
Uh,
he was doing that,
but what's like a guitar?
And he was just creating these songs and then I had to jump in and play drums
and it was just a whole other fucking animal and I realized that all these years
I thought that I played drums.
I didn't,
I like do drums.
I was talking about somebody who bought that today.
I like do drums,
I don't play them.
You know what I mean?
Playing them is what I attempted to do with the other night and failed
horrifically.
See if you fucking listen to a song and you listen to what the drummer's doing,
you figure it out,
then you play it.
That's like getting all the answers to the test and then the drum part fit,
fix fits because the other guy already came up with it but you,
somebody just starts playing you a piece of music you never heard of and then
you have to actually come up with the drum part.
You are the level of musician that you are as immediately exposed and there's
nowhere for you to hide
and that was just,
I had a great time.
I had such a fucking fun time doing it,
but I was actually thinking,
I was like,
wow man.
I knew I sucked.
I didn't know I sucked.
Wow.
Um,
but it was a,
it was so much fun and the person was really,
really generous and I want to thank him for a fucking
hang in that long with me.
But it was such a fun fucking time and it was also,
you know,
it was a very huge learning.
It wasn't,
yeah,
there was a few moments I actually thought I played pretty good.
But other than that I was just like,
Jesus Christ just kept trying to do stuff and then,
you know,
you just make that face.
Like I'm not bad at that too.
I don't know if you professional drummers can try and fill in you don't you fuck
up,
you know,
do you make a face?
Cause I always do.
I make that,
oops,
you don't have face John Paul Jones made when him and bought him fucked up in a
song remains the same.
They came in a little too early.
But John Paul Jones says back to the crowd and you see bon and looked down and
he just kind of shakes his head for half a second and then they got it right.
Um,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I'm just trying to fill up this fucking half hour cause I have no fucking time.
I have no time in my life anymore.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I need to,
I need a pharmacist in my fucking life.
You know what?
You know why I don't take those aside from the,
that I don't want to get addicted is uh,
yeah.
What I like about drinking is I enjoy the effort it takes to get the buzz.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't like,
uh,
like we just seem so easy,
especially now with all these fucking vaporizers and stuff.
I'll you inhale,
you're doing that anyways.
Then you just sit there and all of a sudden Amy and blah,
blah,
like with fucking drinking,
you gotta drink it.
Okay.
If you're going to get shit faced,
just drinking beer,
that's a lot of Goddamn work.
You've got to drink,
eat,
drink,
at least six of them.
If you're a lightweight,
upwards of fucking,
you know,
I don't know,
36 to 40 depending on how about you drink.
So anyway,
anyways,
look at this shit.
So I went to this,
um,
this website.
Okay.
And it was like what is the difference between heroin and Percocet?
And this is like fucking nuts.
This is like people who were like on these drugs talking in this,
this chat room.
Like what is the difference?
Someone told me I should buy some versus buying 30 milligrams of oxycodone
because it should be a lot cheaper.
So what are your opinions?
So many top basically told this person who is addicted to these,
this fucking oxy,
they should now get heroin.
So this guy just,
this is such like,
like they're talking about cars or some shit.
This person says,
well,
they are both strong narcotics.
Heroin is an opiate and oxycodone is an opioid,
which is basically in layman terms,
opioids are synthetics and opiates occur naturally.
And the opium poppy and my opinion,
heroin is stronger.
But then that's countered by the fact that you'll never know street heroins
purity.
And you always know what's in an oxy,
am I saying that right?
Oxycodone,
tablet.
If you buy 30 milligrams of 30 milligram tablet,
you know how strong it is.
Heroin purity can go up and down and they cut it with all kinds of shit.
These are fucking people doing hard drugs.
First of all,
I'm going to give it up that they could still fucking had the sense to go into a
chat room.
Okay.
And compare fucking notes.
So there's a lot of people talking about this,
but not in,
not on CNN,
on Fox News or any of those other fucking so called news channels where they're
all bought and paid for.
And they're not going to do this fucking story because you know,
the same companies that get everybody allegedly got everybody addicted or
advertising on their fucking channels.
Um,
so all Hio is suing drug companies over their role in creating an opioid
epidemic,
which has led to an opiate epidemic.
Uh,
because after a while they won't fill your fucking prescription.
So NPRs Robert Siegel talks with the Ohio attorney general,
or just get to the bullshit here.
The state of Ohio figures,
it's home to 200,000 opiod addicts.
That's the equivalent.
The population of Akron overdoses are so common.
The morgues and some Ohio counties lack for space.
Today's Ohio today,
Ohio's attorney general announced he's bringing a suit against five drug
manufacturers accusing them of misrepresenting the risk of prescription opioids
and helping to fuel an addiction epidemic in this state.
Yeah.
Like these people are like murdering people.
Okay.
If what they're saying is true,
that's what the fuck they're doing.
And these fucking cunts,
these corporate cons state,
they go to bed fucking silk pajamas,
indoor and outdoor pool is everybody's fucking died.
I Dunno,
the uh,
population control person in me sorta like I'm on both sides of this thing.
It's like,
this is fucking terrible that do to people.
Then it's also like,
well,
there's 20 people on the planet,
so thank God these fucking psychos are killing people so they can get a bigger
house.
I heard the like,
you know,
any doctors listen to this shit anonymously want to write in.
I mean I heard that they have like these pharmaceutical companies,
they hire these hot chicks to walk around to bring in the new drugs were in like
fuck me pumps and stuff.
Is that true or did it,
was I half asleep watching some red shoe diary one night?
I thought it was in this industry.
I have no idea.
So the State Attorney General Mike,
the win or,
or wine as he know,
as he's known around the way,
joins us now from Columbus.
Welcome to the program.
Once again,
I'll fuck this.
This,
the uh,
somebody who the fuck would read this?
This is for like deaf people who can't hear NPR.
Okay.
Mike d y good to be back.
Thank you very much Segal.
And first tell us which companies have you named in the suit.
Okay.
We have sued the following companies,
Purdue Pharma,
endo health solutions,
Jansen or Jansen pharmaceuticals.
Cephalon and then Allergan.
Why the fuck?
Why won't you just summarize all of this?
I guess I can hit play.
It's a five minute interview.
I don't have time for that shit.
U US officials are starting to treat opiod companies like big tobacco about time
and how city is suing pharmaceutic don't vilify drug companies says cvs.
Really?
Oh Jesus.
He bought and paid for these fuckers wallet.
But you know what?
I want to hear their opinion first.
Only America would vilify the people that invented Viagara.
That's what happened.
That's what's happening.
Parentheses sort of.
They just bought back everything they just said this week is the FDA holds very
public hearings and the potential health risks of popular prescription pain
medication such as Cox,
two inhibitors,
Pfizer,
the company that makes one of those medicines.
Celebrex is also the company that brought you in yours.
Viagra,
drug companies,
big farmers.
The villains of medicine and healthcare,
at least according to much media.
Who the fuck wrote this horseshit.
This is by,
I swear to God,
booty cost Grove Mather.
All right.
I don't understand how you can be anywhere in journalism with a first name
booty.
All right.
Have I,
have I made enough of an ass of myself talking about this shit?
Um,
you know I love about this country is horse can give press conferences.
All right,
let's do some.
Uh,
all right,
let me do a little advertising here.
Oh,
look who's back.
Indochine or Indochino.
Uh,
talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
Listen,
I've always been attracted to men,
but nothing gets my loins going.
Like seeing another man walked by in a suit.
Something about hearing those slacks rubbing together.
Indochina.
China is making it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit at an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top quality fabrics.
It personalize your suit just the way you want it,
whether it works,
whether it's for work or a wedding or another special occasion.
Okay?
Going to work is not a special occasion.
That's what the fuck are you up to?
A wedding special occasion.
Where are you going,
honey,
to a special occasion?
All I'm going to work well,
what the fuck is it?
He's going to work.
Indochino has suited up hundreds of thousands of men and and now the largest
made to measure men's brand,
men's wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
Does it a showroom or stop online@indochino.com pick your fabric.
Pick your poison.
Choose your customizations from lapels to pleats to jacket linings and more.
Well,
what the fuck else is their shoulders.
Submit your measurements.
Place your order and wait for it to arrive at just a few weeks.
You had a robot shows up wearing your jacket.
Fucking choke shout this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 379 bucks it
indochino.com when entering bird at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochine.
no.com Promo code bird for any premium suit for just three to $79 and free
shipping.
It's an incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could.
All right.
Oh,
look who's here.
Look who's here.
It's sold zip.
Are you hiring?
Yeah.
Well,
are you?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding you.
Fuck you.
You talk about it with Ziprecruiter.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently,
the right people to your job better than anyone else.
That is why zip
udub is different.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
It finds them
all right?
It's like that guy chasing fucking the guy crashed a plane,
Hans Solo,
you know would that guy,
the guy from no country for old men?
Okay,
he's going to find you.
Tommy Lee Jones,
Harrison Ford,
Bam,
Bam.
It's in it.
In fact,
80% of employees who post a job on zip,
okay,
get a quality candidate through this site within just one day.
No juggling fucking emails or calls to your office.
You don't have time for that shit.
You got to hit the golf course.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with zip.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most quality job qualified job candidates with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free.
That's right.
Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's right.
ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
Great.
If for free had zip.
Okay.
Calm slipper,
right?
Oh,
look who's here.
All right,
everybody.
You weren't taught all week.
You worked hard all week.
Why not fucking take your paycheck and throw it on some football games?
Draft kings,
everybody.
Football season has began and it's not too late to take your paycheck.
Stick it on the table and never fucking see it again.
Or you get closer to the game you love with draft kings.
One week fantasy football.
This Sunday Ram kings is hosting at $100,000 pick 'em contest that is totally
fucking breed.
Andrew [inaudible] is the newest way to play one week fantasy football.
The one night stand of sports gambling.
Draft your team.
Drafting your team is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized players into eight tiers.
All you have to do according to what?
Skin color.
How are you doing this?
All you have to do is select.
Are there eight different skin colors?
Well,
if you get into shade,
Sarah,
if you just like a racist person,
there's like black,
white,
Asian,
native American,
Italian.
I don't what the fuck I was serious.
Choose between public contest with big cash prizes or private contests where you
can compete against a group of your friends.
Draftkings also has beginner in casual contest where you can play against people
of the same similar skill level.
Everybody gets a trophy.
The best part is he get to draft a new team each week,
week without any commitment.
So get you know,
and if your team shits the bed,
you don't have to pack and leave town like Pete Carroll when he ran out the back
door.
So get the draft kings.com now and use Promo Code Burr to play and draftkings
free contest with $100,000 in total prices this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code Burr to play for free this Sunday.
This that's Promo Code [inaudible] at draftkings.com eligibility restrictions
apply.
See draftkings.com for details.
All right,
the last fucking read.
This is the last fucking re he dad I have to do.
Oh my God,
that was a little Don Henley.
Remember Don and he put out that great fucking album,
the late eighties what a songwriter.
What a showman.
A lift.
Everybody.
Lyft knows that drivers are what keeps them moving so they do everything they
can to make sure their drivers are happy on every trip.
Lift believes that being a ride sharing driver should be fun if you're having a
good time off,
so the passengers,
if you're choosing a ride sharing company to drive for,
go with the company that treats you better.
It's lift,
not like those slave driving bastards over at Uw.
At Uber,
you want to go with Lyft.
You get tips at this fucking place.
The only tip she get it.
Uber is,
hey,
here's a tip.
You ain't making shit here,
so shut the fuck up and keep driving.
That's how they treat them over there,
right?
Lyft is the North Sea.
I mean Uber is the North Korea of ride sharing apps.
Live was the first to offer in APP tipping.
Can imagine a few are fucking Lyft driver and you picked up Kim Jong Il or maybe
just somebody who looked like,
you know what I mean?
You're like,
well,
he wouldn't be over here.
He doesn't like us.
Maybe that's just some fat Asian kid who likes to have a Hitler youth haircut.
I don't know.
We go and serve
to the airport.
Lyft was the first offer.
Inept tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $200 million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly instead of where you for
weeks,
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
One,
earn more money,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers means happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating
the others and in a fiery crash.
So join the ride sharing company that believes in treating people,
treating its people better.
Go to lift.com/burr today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's right.
lyft.com/ [inaudible] it's a limited time only.
L Y F t.com/ [inaudible] that's it.
Fuck you.
I'll talk to you later.
Um,
honestly,
32 minutes.
Okay.
People,
I want you guys all have a wonderful weekend.
I want you to get on your knees and give thanks that you don't live in the
Caribbean with all them tornadoes coming.
Why don't we say tornadoes?
Hurricanes coming.
Yeah.
Uh,
everybody in Puerto Rico.
I hope you make it out.
All right.
I just saw it was coming yesterday,
man.
It's fucking brutal,
It's really brutal.
The same way they going after these pharmaceutical companies for a,
the,
you know,
the opioids,
opioids,
ob and cheese,
the Indochino s right?
They should go after fucking fossil fuel companies at some point.
That's going to fucking happen,
you know?
But she can never get the people that made the decision.
Because what you're doing is you're,
you're suing a corporation,
which is nameless and faceless.
And then all those people who made those fucking decisions collectively turn
your key.
They all turned their fucking key.
I was following orders.
All of those fucking cuts when you go to sue the company,
or completely insulated,
and they will be giving themselves raises with their blood money.
And then when they go to fucking attack the company,
everybody just fucking walks away.
He's like,
well,
I worked there.
I am not,
you know,
I'm not the corporation.
Yeah.
Why are you still talking?
I'm sorry.
I gotta go to fucking bed.
Alright.
Anyways,
don't be a cut this weekend.
Everybody up and don't watch the fucking news.
All it's gonna do is make you feel fucking sad.
Go out.
Be a good person.
You know,
somebody asks you to get in the trunk.
Just,
you know,
just don't do it.
That's all I'm saying.
All right.
Does that make any sense?
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Uh,
please enjoy this music as we a,
you're going to get another half hour of fucking riveting entertainment like the
last fucking 33 minutes of this shit show from a Thursday afternoon podcast
that's gone by,
you know,
Thursday from another year or possibly earlier this month.
All right,
I'll see all you people in Toronto.
I can't wait to go up there and give you my brand new hour of fucking bullshit.
I'll be there with Paul Versey.
That dude,
I called a kid the pride or New Jersey,
you know,
Sunday Paul verse.
He's going to walk through the pearly gates wearing a brand new pair of Jordan
three S.
It's fucking dope.
Did Jordan trees with my angel soap
and those wingstone over.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
I've got,
see what's,
I'm just theme Fiesta Day.
Got Up the sand.
Oh,
I'm just
goes,
oh.
He goes,
Ooh,
all right.
X Defense Minister from Canada speaks out about,
speaks,
speaks about.
See,
this is what not.
Once again,
not my fault.
This person writes x defense minister from Canada speaks about out about aliens
out about aliens or speaks out about aliens or does he speak about out about
aliens?
See what I'm saying?
Okay.
This isn't always me.
All right.
Bill loved the podcast,
freelance every week.
Uh,
they're much appreciated,
Yada,
Yada.
I thought you might like this link as you're a big conspiracy theory.
A big conspiracy theorist.
You mean?
He said it's the former Canadian defense administrator.
No Canadian defense minister giving some bold claims about several species of
aliens living among us and actually working with elements in the government.
Uh,
not only that,
but a shadow.
We,
okay.
Cabal.
C A,
B,
a,
l,
k,
but k bell,
I dunno.
Comprised of the council on foreign relations.
The bill,
the Burgers,
the tea
trilateral commission.
That should add a hyphen in it.
You can't.
The international banking cartel,
uh,
the oil cartels,
members of various intelligence organizes the select members of the military
agenda.
This is the one world government.
Check it out,
sir.
The last thing I'm going to do is look at this.
I'll put the link up there.
Ah,
fuck it.
I'll look at it right now.
This shit just freaks me out.
It makes me depressed because there's nothing I could do about it.
Okay.
Now,
how is this gonna help me,
sir,
if I find out there's actually aliens living among us,
talking to international bankers,
you know,
am I going to come walking in,
bursting into their meeting like the end of a feel good movie.
Okay.
You know,
like,
hey man,
the people have spoken and they liked me.
All right,
here we go.
I got it right here.
Uh,
Canada's former minister of national defense,
Paul Haler testifies at the citizen's hearing on disclosure,
where the fuck am I last month in Washington DC that aliens are living among us
and that it is likely at least two of them are working with the u s government.
Oh,
this guy sounds like he's out of his fucking mind.
Ugh.
Let,
let's,
let's kind of flip the script here.
Let's say you're an alien.
All right?
Whoever's listening to this still,
who believes in aliens who wasn't blogging about my reaction to the blogger?
Um,
okay.
Can you go to what?
You go to another fucking solar system now,
the galaxy,
whatever the fucking terminology is,
and you land there,
okay,
what are you going to do other than try and get blended,
blend in so people don't shop your fucking alien head off.
Like how exactly did this fucking alien
get infiltrate the government.
This is like Mr. Smith goes to Washington,
the alien just lands and just goes,
okay.
Ah Right.
I mean,
how come he didn't do this in Argentina?
We picked the United States,
goes right into fucking Washington.
DC walks into the Capitol building as somebody somebodies filibustering so they
can't make an electric car or whatever comes right out on the house floor and
then does what,
you know,
security comes up,
tries to shoot him and he just puts his hands up in their guns,
turned into like chocolate bars or fall to the ground.
And then for some reason everybody in their suits doesn't scramble and freak the
fuck out.
Okay.
You know?
No,
he just fucking walk out there as,
hey,
let's go and I'll relax,
relax,
relax.
It's a simple technology that you guys will discover if you become friends with
me.
Hide attorney fucking gone into some melted shit that a doesn't let people shoot
you.
I am from the planet.
Zoll Tar.
Right.
It always begins with z.
How does that work?
Okay.
Like if you were a fucking alien and you went to another God damn planet.
Exactly.
I guess.
Okay.
You'd be like,
all right,
if there's a bunch of different nations,
which one seems to be running?
Shit,
I got to chop the head off and you just gonna Watch you when you were in a
buddy,
two of you
gonna walk in fucking arm and arm
and do what?
Yeah.
Hey,
listen.
I think just the simple fact that we were able to get here,
you know,
the kind of firepower that we're capable of,
uh,
for some fucking reason we want to take over this planet or we want you guys to
do shit the way we feel that the it should be done.
Who?
Who would want that fucking headache?
I don't,
I don't know that I believe this shit anyways.
He believes Hellyer whose beliefs on extra life extra to your life and you are
so your foes are well established.
Made the statements at the nongovernmental hearings chaired by six former US
congressmen and aimed at according to the events website,
doing what the u s congress had failed to do for 45 years.
Seek out the facts surrounding the most important issue of this or any other
time evidence pouring towards an extraterrestrial presence,
engaging the human race.
All right.
You know what,
even I have my limits when it comes to that type of shit.
All right.
I don't think that's the most pressing thing I would say.
Yeah,
I was fucking up the environment,
world population and that type of shit.
It's a little more,
unless you want to throw more people from other galaxies.
Also living here.
Do they drink bottles?
Water too?
Um,
all right,
sisters a through c.
Here we go.
Uh,
tired of giving advice to guys with psycho suicidal girlfriends or people with
STDs.
Well I got something a bit lighter,
a few here.
A kind of like the cores lite version of your typical advice.
Thank you.
And is perfect for the middle of the summer.
We kicked my feet back on this one so I know this.
Okay.
Who I'd been friends with,
uh,
for a while now and banged one time.
She's the oldest of three sisters,
so we all call her sister a.
About two years ago I made out with sister,
be in a club,
not my initiative.
Um,
and ended up having sex with there the same night.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I went out with her.
Do,
do they have like that thing on the back of their SUV where they had the stick
figures of the entire family and you just slowly keep exiting them out
and the family doesn't understand if somebody's trying to kill my daughters.
No,
just trying to fuck all of them,
sir.
Well,
that's a relief.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
I went out with her for a while.
Oh,
this is sister B.
And it was surprisingly not awkward when we were hanging out all together,
even though everyone knew the situation.
Jesus Christ.
What's southern state are you in sir?
Um,
I'll go fuck yourself people down south.
That was funny.
Um,
I'm some months later,
sister be left me for one of her,
one of my friends and got over it quickly enough.
But when got over it quickly enough and nowadays I'm still in contact with
sister a and B since I'm not the Kinda guy that holds a grudge for that kind of
stuff.
Well there you go.
It's very mature,
which means you really didn't give a fuck about either one of them.
So why are you going to be all upset?
You know,
like you own their pussy once you fuck it.
I hate when,
I hate when guys do that.
Anyways,
recently since sisters see started talking to me more frequently after talking
for a bit,
she said she could pose for me since I'm a painter and she's a model and a 10
all the fucking way I might add,
oh you fucking creep.
You fucking creep.
So she was a 10 the whole time.
So basically you're in a holding pattern banging her oldest sisters waiting
until this girl was of age so he could fucking painter Jesus Christ.
I got to,
I,
you know,
I might have to stand up and applaud this one.
This guy is taking it to another level.
This is a fucking epic situation here.
So you'll see.
Here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Do you need my advice?
I need advice from you.
How do you fuck every girl in the same family?
Jesus Christ.
This is like,
do you know how long there's been an it's been since it's been a triple crown
winner in horse racing.
The last time someone won the Kentucky Derby,
the Preakness and the breeders' Cup.
Is that what it is or is that a soccer match?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
No fucking horse.
Since the late seventies I would guarantee that it's been since the late
seventies sent somebody has boost bank three.
I think a lot can do two in one family,
but to get all fucking three,
two,
three,
two is a respectable three is no,
it's beyond respectable.
Two.
Three.
Okay.
Everybody who was three years in the sporting world do that.
That's a fucking dynasty.
Okay.
You just put yourself in there with fucking Bill Russell.
You put yourself in there with,
with,
with the fucking,
uh,
Magic Johnson Lakers,
you know,
I wouldn't say the Colby Lakers.
You know when you go out and you get Phil Jackson and fucking check,
then it,
that's that new shit that the kids like.
I don't like that shit
either way,
dude.
You're talking fucking dynasty.
Oh wait,
magic never won three in a row,
but he had the Celtics to fuck with named went three out of four years.
Give me a fucking break.
Um,
so here's my Michael Jordan.
There we go.
So here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Is it a trap?
Should I try to bang her?
Should I try and bang her too and get a third strike or keep my dick in my pants
and avoid a potential shit storm?
And if yes,
do you have any tips,
special tips on this special situation?
All my friends are telling me to do so,
but I thought I'd ask a more refined mine like yourselves before I did a move.
Dude,
you are looking at me like,
dude,
you're beyond me right now.
Okay.
This is like Bull Durham.
I'm,
I'm fucking Kevin Costner.
Um,
I'm,
I'm a lifer.
Okay.
You're,
you're,
you're going up to the show hidden brand new balls every fucking day.
I will.
I will you tell me.
Okay.
I never banked two girls in one fucking family.
You know,
I was psyched if I was able to tag a couple of friends and we were all hanging
out at a bar one night.
And you get that feeling like I fuck both of you and you both know it and you
both loved it.
I hope.
Please,
please tell me you liked it.
Did you like it was I okay?
Um,
dude,
I think you got to do it.
You gotta do it.
You know,
you,
you've been above board the whole time.
Sister.
Rain seems to be,
they all fucking knew everything right now.
I understand this is a little delicate.
Okay.
He's trying to snip the last wire here.
This is the kid sister.
This is,
is it going to blow up in your fucking face?
Uh,
it's worth it,
dude.
It's worth it.
It's worth losing a couple of limbs and you nose on this one.
You got to do it
to fuck you know,
dude,
what the fuck
she says to you,
I,
yeah,
you're,
you're a painter.
All let me take my clothes off and get paid my fucking Twat.
That's not art today.
That's foreplay.
Give me a fucking break.
If you,
one thing,
if you're in a classroom of people,
it's just you and she's standing there naked
dude.
That's like one of the tabs they have had done that porn cinema,
that scenario in a porn at Jesus Christ,
you might have fun.
A new angle
through.
That's phenomenal.
That is fucking phenomenal,
dude.
You got to do it.
Did John Elway retire when he only got one?
He came back for another,
right?
You got to do it to do the w
two that's like when Bush fucking the first Bush.
He stopped and he didn't get sit down.
You got to go all the way on this one,
man.
All right.
You gotta be like Marlon Brando in fucking apocalypse now.
He just,
you just,
you just accept the fact you left the program.
All right,
and
I don't care how mad these girls get,
dude,
you are at the precipice of becoming an absolute fucking legend.
Legend.
Who could,
who could,
who's going to be able to top that dude?
There is celebrities who've had orgies,
they've had five on ones and all that type of Shit,
okay?
But I guarantee you they never fucked three fucking girls in the same family
when they weren't famous,
not famous.
You're doing this shit with the gift of Gab.
Whatever the fuck you're doing,
do you do this?
You got to write a book.
You gotta write a book that's,
you know,
that's easy to do.
Collection of the most amazing pussy getting stories ever that you can somehow
confirm,
all right?
And it has to be none of that bullshit.
The second you get famous,
you get money.
That doesn't count,
all right?
That's garbage time,
okay?
They put the fucking second team in there and you just fucking Titone layups.
That's bullshit.
I'm talking about just regular dude.
You do.
You talk yourself into it through the,
and you're a fucking legend.
You got to do it.
All right?
This might halftime speech.
I'm going to quote Joe Barton.
Nick quoting John Madden today is going to be the greatest day of your life,
but only if you win.
All right,
you got to do it.
He got to fucking dude keypad in
the future.
Hey,
what's going on?
This is bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 21st,
2009.
This is like the fifth time I've tried to start this thing.
I don't know where to begin this week.
Uh,
I am psyched because I am in Los Angeles,
at least for today and tomorrow before I fly right back out again.
I'm getting ready to do another special.
So I have to,
I'm in comedy bootcamp right now.
I did a Gig at Boston University this weekend,
the weekend before I was in Philadelphia,
the weekend before I was in Stockholm,
Sweden.
Let me think.
I had a week off and now I got to,
I got a four week intensive right here or I just keep fucking going out and,
uh,
my,
my act is going to get really tight during this time.
But,
um,
you ever see those fat people on the biggest loser where they're like,
they're losing weight,
but that look of pain when they're on the treadmill?
That's what I have right now.
If the standup comedy version of that,
you know,
where there's some,
a good looking woman who sort of manly standing over me going,
you've got to tell more jokes.
Do you guys watch a show?
Biggest loser deck?
Did the girl on the woman,
the female,
the broad on that show is like,
I dunno,
she's really,
really hot.
But she's really like manly and I don't mean she looks like a mess.
She just moves.
There's like nothing dainty about her.
And she's some girl you kind of play fight with and then she just unleashed one
into your ribs and you'd be like,
okay,
you definitely had older brothers because you know how to throw a punch.
Why are your eyebrows so big?
All right.
So if you're new to the podcast and I can't figure out why this fucking thing
keeps red line in like that,
turn down the record level here.
Maybe that's the problem.
Um,
if you new to this podcast,
I do one of these every God damn week.
I've been doing them for about two years at this point and I pretty much,
uh,
I don't think I've really missed a week really.
I mean,
occasionally I put them in on Tuesdays,
but generally speaking,
I don't miss a week.
So they come out every Monday and people send me in questions,
they send me in their list of stuff that they feel is underrated.
Overrated.
We recommend some youtube videos and websites.
We interpret dreams.
No,
actually we don't.
You know what,
that was one that I always want,
I've been meaning to do.
Um,
people keep asking me for advice and it keeps getting deeper and deeper and
deeper and um,
evidently I haven't,
I've been getting some decent reviews with my advice,
but you got to understand,
you're talking to guys pretty much fucked up in every area of his life.
Like here's one for Ya.
Let me see if I can find this one.
Actually,
the how was,
I was on the plane and I was going through the emails.
I guess I'll have to paraphrase.
This guy basically sent me in one
that was asking advice and he said that he was,
he was married to a Chinese woman
who was like seven years older than him.
They had a 10 year old kid and he was from like Vietnam.
I don't fucking remember,
but all I know is they got a kid and he's tired.
He's not attracted to her anymore.
And he wanted some advice and it's just like to,
I,
I don't know.
I mean that sounds about right.
You know,
you've been together for how long now?
Why would I say something like that?
See,
that's why I don't want to,
I don't want to fucking talk about stuff that that's got,
that's,
that's that fucking deep,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I can see that.
I think that's normal.
Don't they call it like the seven year itch?
You know,
you were in a relationship for like seven years or so,
or maybe 10 years and after awhile it's like,
you know,
when it comes to the physical thing,
it's like there's no room left in your house where you haven't fucked.
There's no position that you haven't done,
you know,
I mean my girls a pain in the ass.
She was just walking out of the room,
threw her head back.
Are you serious?
Are you seriously going to talk about me this week?
Cause if you are,
I'm going to storm out.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know what to tell you.
Why do you always do that?
Nia,
you just stick your head in you.
You start looking at me like that's gonna make me not be an asshole.
I'm always going to be an asshole.
Um,
so anyways,
this is what I,
this is what I did.
This is why you can't be here when I do these.
Nia,
you have to leave.
Close the door.
Be a good girl.
Come on,
come in here.
All right,
well what?
You're distracting me.
Close the door.
Oh,
that's a good girl.
You're the worst.
You just keep walking in and out.
It's fucking brutal.
11 1213 seconds wasted.
Oj,
when you girl puts on flip flops,
that's still worse.
When they're being annoying and you keep hearing the sound of that Sandal
hitting the fucking healer,
their foot,
and you need to be a little more sensitive and then that silence CTA or you're
walking through some horrific mall that you don't even want to be in.
Oh,
look at those sunglasses,
those acute,
I want sunglasses.
And you go,
there you go,
guys.
That's how you get rid of your girl.
Just start trashing what they're wearing.
And then they store them up,
you know?
And then I guarantee you six hours from now she'll be like,
do you really not like when I wear flip flops?
I thought you liked them with,
oh my God,
why didn't you say something?
I just feel so stupid right now.
You know,
we,
she had an argument about health,
you know,
I know I can't stand about fucking women.
I just do this every week.
But it's annoying.
It's frustrating.
I can't fucking stand the way they turn.
Little things.
Nothing into these big fucking dramatic falconcrest fucking moments where all of
a sudden like I'm supposed to feel like,
sorry,
I can't fucking stand that.
You know,
like I was flying back yesterday.
I couldn't,
you know,
from the east coast,
I can't find my keys.
All right.
Now for those of you who listen to my podcast all the time,
you know that I drive a hybrid like a fig.
I drive a Prius,
right?
It's a great fucking car.
I totally recommend it.
Especially if you live in a city.
Why would you buy a sports car in a city?
Huh?
You're going to be stuck in traffic.
The car's going to get all fucked up cause you can't blow out the lines or
whatever the fuck you supposed to do.
Actually reality is I can't afford the car.
I want it.
So I'm just going to trash people who can anyways,
plowing ahead.
So how it works with the Fancy Prius is you don't have to stick your key in the
lock.
And you know what?
I don't even have to press a button as long as it's on you.
The second you get in the vicinity of the handle and you touch it,
it unlocks.
Okay.
Which you know,
is supposed to be like,
wow,
we really are going to fucking have flying saucer Sundaes like moment,
you know,
so evidently,
but that,
that little mechanism that's supposed to make my life so much easier.
If I lose that thing,
it costs like two or 300 bucks to get a new one.
And I can't just be like,
well why don't you just give me one that has a fucking key on it?
Cause I don't think that that option exists.
Does it now?
Maybe it does.
I don't fucking know.
So all I know is I thought I lost like that two or $300 thing.
I hung around watching the Patriots.
The game went a little bit long cause it was country refs call the fucking
penalty every two seconds.
So now I was in jeopardy of missing my flight and I can't find my keys.
So I'm rushing around the house.
I tore apart my luggage like twice.
All right.
And then I call my girl up and she answers the phone.
I'm like,
Hey,
did I leave my keys out in la?
They'll leave my keys out in la.
She goes,
um,
yeah,
you left him in the car.
I said,
okay,
cool.
All right.
I'll,
ah,
no,
no.
She answered it right.
Why?
I said,
she goes,
yeah,
you left them in the car.
And I said,
okay.
Okay.
All right,
cool.
I'll call you from the airport.
And she just goes,
okay,
that's yeah,
that you talk to me for a minute.
You know,
they create that fucking moment.
You know what I mean?
This is why women are not in battle in war.
Right fucking there.
He'd start giving quit fucking,
you know,
orders fakey asking me how my day and the Fox Hall went first before he just
started telling me the charge up the hill.
No,
that's okay.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't tolerate that.
So when they say shit like that,
well I guess,
I guess you,
they're too busy to talk to me.
That's right.
I am.
All right.
See you later.
Okay.
You know,
and then you just fucking go.
Four three,
two,
one.
And then the phone calls again.
What's the problem?
Is there a problem?
And then you're in it.
You're in the fucking fight that they wanted to.
Yeah.
You just can't fucking actually,
you can win.
You can win.
You just going to live a lonely life,
but you can win.
And speaking of that,
this is something I've learned the other,
you know,
I use the word control a lot here on my podcast and uh,
I don't know how they hell I came across this,
but I would like to read to you guys about a street that existed in the Middle
Ages by the name of grope cut lane.
I'm not bullshitting you grope cunt lane,
pronounced grope cunt lane or they come late.
They have to have that.
Like I can't read English.
Okay.
Was his street name found in English towns and cities during the middle ages
believe to be a reference to the prostitution centered on those?
Uh,
in those areas it was normal practice for medieval names,
street names to reflect the streets function or economic activity taking place
within it.
Grope.
Cont
the earliest known use of,
which is about 1230 after the death of that dude that everyone thought was holy,
appears to have been derived as a compound of the words grope and can't,
don't you hate when people explain obvious shit?
Like really?
Yeah.
I couldn't put the two of those grope cunt.
What are the Wa everyone knows what groping is,
you know,
there's
no other word for what,
what else can grope mean
and can't is,
yeah,
yeah.
GRUB contact.
Got It.
Why don't we have puberty lately on this?
I got it,
Ma.
I really like this girl in class.
What do I say?
Um,
streets with that name.
We're often in the busiest parts of medieval towns and cities.
Yeah,
it's a red light district and at least one appears to have been an important
thoroughfare.
Um,
although,
although the name was once commonly common throughout England,
changes in attitude results resulted in,
it's being replaced by more innocuous versions such as grape lane
grope was last recorded as a street name in 1561.
You know what I mean?
So all you guys out there,
you still have cool names for your stadiums and now you have a,
I need a job.com arena as opposed to like war memorial coliseum.
It's been going on forever.
All right.
And you know when they changed it to grape lane that there was people who still
called it grope cunt.
And then there was people like it's it's group alone.
Okay,
have a little bit with clues.
Um,
go fuck yourself.
What are people doing down there on grape lane?
You know what that is just the beginning of like dead clean comedy and why you
know something you need.
You need grape lane for grope con to be funny.
You need grape lane.
I'm full of Shit.
It's just fucking annoying me.
Like does,
does that mean because you call it grape lane,
does that mean that there's any less fucking women down there getting,
you know,
getting their consc groped?
You know,
do you guys know what I got?
I got an email from somebody.
Uh,
I dunno,
a priest,
a pastor.
Uh,
I dunno what the fuck it was.
Some person who a holy person and said that they saw me on TV and that they
thought I was absolutely hilarious,
but they wished that I hadn't cursed as much because it was getting beeped out a
lot.
And then they stumbled across my podcast and thought the podcast was also
hilarious,
but just could not get past the fact of how much I curse.
And,
um,
I don't understand people.
I can see if you have a child there,
but I just don't understand like adults who just like,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
dude,
you're on the Internet.
Okay.
What?
There's nothing I'm saying that's going to be shocking.
Good Lord.
I Dunno.
You know,
is he right?
I don't fucking know.
You know what?
I don't have class.
Okay.
You know what they don't like about having class?
There's this,
there's,
there's a lack of honesty to it.
You know what I mean?
The,
you put on a pair of a pair of loafers and a blazer,
okay.
And all of a sudden Peabo look at him.
He's a gentleman,
he's,
he's quiet.
And then all of a sudden you start calling grope con grape lane and that that's
how it begins.
You know,
you start calling it human resources.
That creepy shit.
I don't fucking know.
You know,
I like to say fuck,
I do.
I like it.
It feels good.
You know,
nothing.
I,
you know,
something people out there who are clean,
who don't curse as much.
Can you,
can you give me a word,
um,
that did,
that,
you know,
when you're angry,
like what word gets it out like that you can stress and the just ends with that.
You know,
you just,
you just stick the landing like fucking Mary Lou Retton anyways,
so whatever.
My point is that there used to be a street called grope current lane,
you know,
back in a more honest time when they could be hedge you every five fucking
seconds.
Um,
you know,
it's one of those deals where you look back on a time and there's certain things
about it that you liked in other aspects you didn't,
I mean,
I liked the fact that the,
where the horse,
we're was called Grope cunt lane.
You know,
I mean,
shit,
you don't even need a map.
You don't need that.
You know why they had that back then?
They didn't have those little tourist brochures to let you know that,
uh,
where are you?
What part of the city you are in?
Oh,
it's right there on the corner of a
fucking raped me and grope cunt.
Oh yeah,
that's the red light district.
Okay,
I got it.
Cool.
You know,
and then the other side was,
uh,
you know,
black,
black Smith row and cobbler fucking lane.
I don't,
I dunno,
you know what?
I'm too stupid to Improv with this right here.
But you know what I'm saying?
Actually,
Bill,
you know what?
We've known what you've been saying for the last 15 fucking minutes.
Why don't you get on with the podcast?
All right?
It's already 1226 out here and I have something to do at one,
so I got to fucking get moving along here.
Um,
oh,
and what I have to start doing is hyping my shit more towards the front because
I think a lot of people get sick of me by the end of it.
God knows I do.
So,
uh,
this week I'm going to be at the Improv in Addison,
Texas,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday and I'm going to the cowboys game,
the Monday night game against the Carolina Panthers on uh,
on the Monday.
So if you see me stumbling through the parking lot because I will be drinking.
All right,
please offer me a burger or something like that because a,
I don't know if I'm going to have,
the person I'm going with is going to have a fucking grill,
you know.
Um,
anyway,
so let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
and after next week,
the week after I'm going to be at the stress factory in New Jersey and the week
after that I'm going to be in Pittsburgh at the Improv.
Then I have a week off.
Then I'm at the Improv in DC,
so there's no excuse to see me on the fucking east coast already cause I just
got back from Boston.
I was in New York in May.
I've been everywhere.
I write.
All right,
Bill.
Exactly.
I know,
I'm sorry.
I just been like a real jerk lately.
I've been really like this how I get when I,
I'm,
I'm under the gun.
I really shouldn't do like podcasts.
I was under the gun last week.
Um,
I dunno,
let's,
let's just plow ahead here.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Now people have been asking me a lot of advice.
Um,
my girlfriend had this real weird dream the other day and I actually interpreted
it to the point where she went,
wow,
that was pretty good.
And I was like,
you know what?
That'd be great.
Should I podcast listeners?
If you have some sort of,
you have ever one of those dreams,
you just have no idea what a fucking meant and maybe you need somebody insight
into it.
Like,
here's one for you.
I had a dream the other day.
I was flying on an airplane.
Okay.
And for some reason I was faced in the opposite direction.
Like I was on a train.
You know,
those little areas where you can have like people face each other and they can
discuss the latest styles.
Like it's the fucking 18 hundreds.
Um,
yeah,
I was sitting like that.
Right.
I was sitting the other way and I was looking through plexiglass and I was
watching George Carlin doing standup.
And for some reason he was missing his right hand.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Holy Shit,
this George Carlin,
I couldn't believe it.
And he's right fucking there.
And what happened to his hand?
And then when we went to get off the plane,
all of a sudden he was really,
really
okay.
Skinny in small and almost looked like an like a woman.
And then I walked around the front,
he had like a beard and he,
and he was missing his fucking hand.
And I,
and I,
what the hell did I say to him?
I said,
I didn't wanna let you know.
You got to think you're really funny,
whatever.
And then now with the eye camera,
what the fuck?
He said to me,
he said something weird back to me and then walked away.
Okay.
And then I got back on the plane like it was a subway and it just continued on
flying somewhere,
you know?
And that's one of those dreams you just say to somebody in,
they're looking at you like,
uh,
I dunno dude.
Maybe you want to fucking,
maybe you're fucking attracted to George Carlin and some fucked up.
I don't fucking know.
It was just a weird ass fucking dream.
Yeah.
Why is he missing a hand?
Why did he look like a woman?
You know,
what's the deal with fucked up dreams if you have fucked up dream like that one.
Cause I can't make heads or tails of that one.
Why was I faced in the opposite direction?
Well,
build in life.
You feel as though,
you know everybody's just going in this one direction and you don't agree with
the direction you're going in the other direction.
Okay?
That's what you feel and you want to get to where some of your heroes are.
But there's this invisible piece of plexi glass.
It seems to stop you from going there.
Okay?
And a lot of times when you don't do what everybody else wants you to do,
they say you're evil.
Okay?
And back in the day when people to write with their left hands,
they thought those kids were demonic and they used to slap their left hand and
make them write with their right hand.
So maybe because you're a hero was on the other side of that glass.
He was evil and that's why he didn't have a right hand.
See,
I can do it.
I could somehow find a fucking through line,
you know?
Okay.
And then maybe you,
you always wanting to hook up with Gloria on a fucking all in the family.
And that's why when you were walking behind George Carlin,
that's what he looked like.
An old Gloria.
All right,
let's fucking,
let's end this.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
we actually,
for the first time on my podcast,
I have a follow up email from somebody that I gave advice to,
to see how shit worked out.
Um,
and of course I can't fucking find it.
Okay.
Why,
why do I do this to myself?
All right.
As I search for it.
I'll tell you,
remember last week when I was telling you about the guy who had his,
uh,
his brother a cock blocked him.
MMM.
You know,
at the party,
he,
you know,
he meets the beautiful girl first.
She asked for a piece of cake.
He said,
I'll go get you one.
He leaves,
he comes back and then his fucking douchebag,
older brother,
he's trying to get her number.
Well,
he wrote me back.
He said,
uh,
well here's what ended up happening.
Um,
no,
that's it.
I don't know.
Okay.
The next day after meeting that 26 year old and having my brother's steal her
numbers,
she ended up requesting me on Facebook.
Got To love the Internet.
He says,
uh,
she then wrote me saying,
nice to meet you.
Thanks for the cake.
I wrote back and we made some conversation,
uh,
where I ended with hope to see you around again.
She agreed and said the same,
so fuck it.
I asked for a phone number.
Needless to say,
she gave it to me.
We played the phone game for a week.
We made plans to go out to some club on Saturday.
By the way,
I'm not much of a dancer,
but if necessary,
I can bullshit my way through it.
Uh,
my luck could not have been any better.
We got there around 3:00 AM and the French she came with,
ended up leaving thinking I was taking her home.
Whether they planned that or not,
I dunno,
but we got to her house and she a little tipsy,
tells me to come up.
Doesn't ask,
would you like to come in?
She casually tells me to come in,
duck getting too crude.
I'm proud to say I fucked the shit out of her.
Funny thing.
While I was bagging her,
I remember thinking to myself,
wait till I tell bill,
dude,
I really hope this story is true.
All right,
cause I want the best for all my 14 podcast listeners.
I hope this happened.
Um,
ha.
anyways,
he said I had to turn my head down and stop myself from laughing.
Now,
my brother,
the cop now for those of you who didn't listen last week or two weeks ago,
whenever the hell I read it,
uh,
her brother's a cop.
All right.
And he's also a cock block and Douche bag.
Evidently.
Um,
the cop works the night shifts.
Dude,
he's not at copies of fucking security guard.
Stop at her.
I was wondering how the hell he became a police officer at 21 probably works at
a video store.
The fucking creep.
Anyways,
he said,
we ended up,
uh,
getting home at the same time,
around 6:00 AM him in his late ships,
late shifts,
security guard brother.
He said,
uh,
I'm not wanting to rub shit in my brother's face,
but he asked me what I ended up doing for the night.
So I simply told him I chilled with that Monica Bitch,
his face said it all with me getting home.
At that time he was able to put two and two together.
I'm not sure whether this counts as a revenge story or not.
Since I didn't take a bat to his squad car or anything,
but with the way shit turned out,
I don't think a revenge is necessary.
Also on a different note,
I,
um,
all right.
So we ended up getting it.
Then the rest is about how he has four dogs and unfortunately he had to put one
down and he told me [inaudible] she gave me good advice.
He goes,
you can't believe how much you miss your dog when it's finally gone.
So make sure you enjoy your dog.
Which I did in which I am.
I wrestled my fucking dog.
The dog likes to wrestle.
Isn't that right?
Clear.
Huh?
Good dog.
You a good dog,
Huh?
Fucking maniac.
You wake me up every morning.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
let's get onto,
um,
how bout some youtube videos for the weekend?
Everybody,
let me scroll down here.
I actually have a website that I think is kind of blowing up on the Internet
right now and I wasn't able to,
uh,
to get to it.
I think it got too many hits.
These kids started it.
It's the name of the website is people of Walmart.
Just search for that.
And I guess these people go,
they just walk around and taking pictures of all the fucking freaks you see in a
Walmart and they just thought it was going to be something that would be funny
amongst them and their friends and somehow and ended up on funny or die.
So evidently it's hilarious.
Uh,
check that out.
And for sports fans,
because we seem to have a lot of them on this,
um,
and even if you're,
you're overseas,
you,
you can,
you can actually enjoy this one search bears fan catch it catches kick on
youtube bears fan catches kick and it was basically from a Monday night football
game about a,
I dunno,
2024 years ago,
25 years in 1985,
24 years ago the bears kick in an extra point.
It's going through the uprights and into the stands and all of a sudden coming
from like the right hand side of the TV screen,
this guy just jumps,
you know,
like a stadium.
Like when you kick an extra point,
it usually goes down and into the alleyway where the,
uh,
the players run into.
That's basically what it was.
This guy's like fucking,
you know,
a good 20 feet in the air.
He,
and the best part of it is he's just completely standing up.
I think I've actually talked about this before in the podcast and he catches the
ball with no fucking concern whatsoever about his own God damn safety.
I Dunno who he landed on our what,
but if he did that today in America,
there'd be some sort of al Qaeda nine 11 fucking group of people that would go
after this guy with his mullet,
new z cavalry cheese.
Like he isn't just some drunk coked up football fan that can jump to stories
without breaking his fucking ankle.
They treat him like he was some sort of terrorist and put his face into the
fucking ground.
But this is back in the day.
All right,
pre all that bullshit.
They actually showed the replay.
We're talking about what a great catch it was in Lynn Swann.
Okay.
The hall of fame fucking wide receiver.
Where I'd one of the best world,
a world series,
best Superbowls ever.
Actually interviews the guy.
So check that one out.
Check that one out.
Why don't you,
um,
all right,
that's it.
Now let,
let me get onto the advice.
Like I said,
I got to blow through it this week.
I apologize.
Um,
hey bill.
So I was going out with this girl.
She was real cute and real funny and we had a lot in common.
I'll do,
this is a bro,
this is a fucking weird story here he goes.
Uh,
we had gone out four or five times,
so I thought I was getting,
you know,
semi serious.
Then one day she called me and told me we had to cancel,
cancel a dinner.
We had planned for later that week.
She had a legitimate reason.
So I was like,
just like,
I fuck it.
Well,
just reschedule.
No biggie.
Right?
So later in the week I call her and get her voicemail and leave her a message
asking if she had,
uh,
she was free a certain day to have dinner.
She never gets back to me.
So I wait a few more days and I call her again.
I ended up leaving another message.
Fucking nothing.
Never calls me back at this point.
I wait about a week and call again and leave one more message.
Not a goddamn thing.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Who does that?
Sorry,
I got lost there.
What the fuck?
Who does that fucking at least call me?
Tell me it's over.
Tell me.
I'm lame.
Say you have to wash your hair or your dog ate your love life,
but fucking call.
I talked to my parents and friends and they have all consoled me and gave me
advice or whatever.
But I needed advice from,
I want you to get some advice from you.
Um,
all right,
well,
let's be honest.
She took the easy way out.
Um,
you know,
she obviously didn't want to see you in anymore obviously,
and yeah,
she,
she took the fucking easy way out and um,
who's getting her breaking up with somebody is one of the hardest things.
The fear of it.
Okay.
You know,
I saw this thing on intervention one time where they were talking about drug
addicts and they say basically they,
they'll spend 20 years avoiding,
you know,
10 days of pain by continuing to medicate themselves because in their head,
the pain of going through,
getting clean is so fucking huge that they,
that they'll contain,
they'll,
they'll go through 20 years of fucking hell.
You know,
and that's what relationships can be like where people get into relationships
and they want to break up with someone.
They just don't know how to fucking do it.
And they're just thinking,
oh my God,
I'm going to break this verse.
It's hard.
They're going to cry.
I want to feel horrible.
Uh,
you know,
for guys,
what if they start screaming and throwing shit and charging me,
you know,
with the salt,
because when they threw a bookcase at me,
it bounced off my big forehead and then hit their big toe,
you know?
Um,
so
I know this is going to sound fucked up,
but his is,
she kind of,
she did you a favor in a weird,
she obviously felt that there wasn't a,
the connection to make it long lasting.
Um,
and I know she took the coward way out,
but at least she,
she,
she figured out a way to get out of it before she fucking rips your heart out of
your chest.
I mean,
I know a probably sucked,
but it didn't seem like,
you know,
you have been gone.
You said you're going to have four or five times.
So I thought it was getting you all right.
See you went,
I like,
you know,
four or five times too.
I mean that's some shit you can get over that at a keg party.
You know,
a couple of fucking plastic 16 ouncers and you grabbed the fucking closest
Hooters looking chick,
you know,
or whatever.
Talk a little bit of Shit.
You know,
she did you a favor man.
So,
I don't know how old you are,
but this girl sounds like you guys sound like you're young and when you're young
you really don't know how to do it.
Um,
the best way I found to do it,
I mean,
we asked,
you should have like a fucking class on that,
how to break up with somebody.
First of all,
you get,
you got to psych yourself up mentally to do it and you just have to be like,
all right,
we're going to talk at two and my life is going to suck from about two to
possibly four 30 or five.
And I just have to understand that the next three hours of my life is going to
suck.
You know?
It's Kinda like if he had to fight a kid after school,
you're like,
okay,
we're fighting around three.
By the time I remember a buddy of mine used to always get into fights for,
because I used to be like,
dude,
how the fuck do you fight?
Like Dan?
He goes,
so I just think in an hour I'm going to be home.
I'm going to be in my bed.
Everything's gonna be fine.
It's kind of the same way I look at like,
you know,
yeah.
If back in the day when I do a college gig and they just had me standing in a
fucking hallway with no microphone and I'm like,
all right,
this is going to be absolutely humiliating.
But in an hour from now,
I'll have my check and I'll be in my fucking,
you know,
Buick Skylark rented from Ava,
so whatever.
And I'll be fucking drab driving away from here and I'll just be a funny story.
Who gives a shit?
So that's kind of what you have to do
and a,
and you can't leave any,
there's no daylight.
And a great way to stop to start is just to say that you're not happy,
you know,
I'm not happy what age you,
I'm just,
I'm not happy.
You know,
you're a great person.
You can,
you know,
all of that type of stuff.
I feel horrible,
but
okay.
You know,
it's not working for me and I have to figure out why.
And I just,
this just doesn't feel right in my,
you go and you just get that out.
And once you get that out,
then the fucking tears and all the bullshit comes and then you just,
you fucking,
you just got to stand there and take it,
you know?
And it's just getting through that first major fucking day of it.
And then you got to have other conversations.
Fucking brutal.
It's fucking brutal.
So getting back to this look,
okay.
You know,
you guys sound like you're young and I just don't think that she has the mental
ability to be like,
yeah,
listen,
you know,
we've gone out like four or five times.
I think you're really nice guy,
but I just don't feel like it's going to go anywhere else above.
And who's kidding?
Who,
if she did that,
you'd still be just as fucking pissed.
But it is weird when they just disappear off the face of the earth like that.
I've,
I've had that man,
I had the classic,
uh,
she's in the shower,
okay.
In a roommate sucked at lying and once she's in the shower,
callback and a half an hour and I called back in a half an hour,
um,
she's repairing her credenza,
callback and 17 minutes and I called back in 17 minutes.
Dude,
I called,
I want a fucking moron,
I must have called like eight times.
And then they finally stopped answering the phone.
You know you ever have that,
like you're avoiding somebody call and in like your thinking there finally not
going to call.
And then the phone rings and you literally get that little fucking heart attack
and your chest.
You almost scared of the God damn phone.
Um,
what I would do,
she did not a break up with you and she did and she did you a favor.
Do cause she could have stuck with you for another six months and you could have
been walking around telling all your friends how much you love her and how great
she is.
And then she dumps you out of fucking nowhere of banks,
one of your friends.
And then you got to carry,
you could carry that shit around for eight years.
And you know what you do get.
It ended up being start going out hurting other girls who had nothing to fucking
do with that.
So in a weird way,
consider yourself lucky you're out of it.
You know,
why would you want to waste any more time with someone who's not NTA anyways?
And you're absolutely right.
It was fucked up.
She should have called you,
but she's just not at that level of maturity and a,
you got a life delete.
So there's no reason to carry around anymore.
You understand me?
So you go out there,
you have a couple of drinks.
She talked some shit to some broads this weekend.
He put her fucking behind you and it's football season.
You know,
we'll fire up the fucking grill and forget about it.
All right,
here we go.
Moving on.
Next one.
Bill,
I watched a couple of your shows and videos that you stand up.
I really enjoy your work.
Thank you.
Uh,
but,
but uh,
all right.
Um,
um,
I've been listening to podcasts.
All right,
here we go am a sophomore and I'm attending a public school that has a
reputation for being dumb.
Where slutty girls and obnoxious boys roam freely until the the bell rings.
You know what school I thought you were describing.
There's a school on the upper west side.
What the fuck?
I think Paris Hilton went to it.
Okay.
Ah,
see I chase me out.
She knew the name of it.
I think it was called the Dwight school
and,
and the people said it stood for
okay.
Dumb White idiots getting high together
cause it gets you all like rich kids.
And this kind of sounded like you were a,
you were describing anyways.
That's a,
that's an old story.
Anyways,
not only does my school have bratty,
annoying,
almost unbelievably ignorant students,
but it is also located in Las Vegas.
So that's right.
That's how I knew it wasn't at school.
Um,
the hottest slash coldest hole in the west.
I am basically a nobody at school.
When other people talk to me in school,
they usually describe me as quiet.
I'm the person who when that one person they talked to all the time doesn't show
up,
seems more lost and more lonely than usual.
I'm very introverted and people don't really warm up to me,
although I secretly wish they would.
My grades are usually high,
but since I have always been Mousey,
I usually have problems making speeches and presentations due to not speaking
loudly enough and not making any eye contact.
I'm easily,
easily embarrassed and mistake prone.
And when I'm around my friends,
friends,
when I'm around my friends,
teachers and anyone I find intimidating,
um,
all I do is sit there arguably hoping I never have to talk to them to sum it up,
I'm socially inept.
You really should have said to sum it up,
you're,
you're a teenager.
This is how I was.
I was socially retarded.
Do you know when I was in,
if I was like right up until like sophomore year in high school,
if a girl even talked to me,
my face turned beet red.
It's fucking embarrassing to admit,
but it's true.
It was pathetic and I was only funny around my immediate group of friends.
If I was in a class and it was basically,
you know,
a middle of the pack class and there was no real popular people in there,
either guys or the cheerleader girls,
then,
um,
then I would be myself.
But if any of the popular P I just knew my role and I just shut the fuck up.
So till this day I have a lot of people who I knew on my past and like,
how the fuck did you end up being a comedian?
Dual,
you'll show fucking quiet because I was a fucking psycho.
Anyways,
person goes on and says the only people who,
uh,
live in this plane,
bug infested house or my mother on a shelf,
but a life or his life,
I don't even know.
I didn't see the,
this was guy or girl,
sorry about that.
A bug infested house on my mother and me.
My Dad pays for the major bills,
like the mortgage and rent,
but doesn't live with us for most of the year.
Uh,
he works as a retired civilian for the navy,
doing janitorial work on the ship channels outside of the country.
Okay.
My mom works currently at a Vietnamese supermarket and as a cashier,
yes she is Vietnamese and like most people from there that I observed,
she cares.
She only cares for Vietnamese and Chinese people.
That's hilarious.
Cause I told that guy he was being sensitive a few weeks ago when he was talking
about the fucking uh,
yeah,
that lady at the front desk or the dentist office being reverse racist.
And I was like,
there was no way that happened.
See,
this is why you shouldn't listen to me.
I don't what the fuck I'm talking about.
And uh,
I'm going to use your mother as the litmus test for everyone in Asia.
I should just shut the fuck up here anyways.
I can't stand her prejudices against other racist.
The biggest,
most recent mistakes she has made so far is she's tried to open a business and
it's failed law in less than a year,
which is pretty pathetic.
We ended up being bankrupt,
um,
and living without water and electricity and had to move around a little bit
after a while.
We had to make a big change in lifestyle,
which was to move
to Las Vegas.
I was furious and upset.
Oh,
I guess this person used to live in San Diego in a neighborhood and always had a
good time out there.
And now you're at the house.
Uh,
my two best friends lived in San Diego and we share so much common knowing each
other in grade school.
And uh,
thirdly,
my sisters would visit me and take me out of the House and away from my mother.
Okay.
Um,
so what are you asking me here?
Did I skip something?
Oh,
I have a major reason why I don't want to leave.
Okay.
Your mom's taking you out there when we lived in a nice looking suburb net.
All my friends are there,
my parents.
So I have,
okay.
Even though I can't get away from my current situation,
a life,
I'm worried about going to college and living on my own was moving away from
your parents and living independently hard for you?
Is there anything I should be warned about?
Uh,
no.
You just need to relax and realize that you're a cool person and you're
overthinking shit,
everything's gonna be fine.
Do you want to learn how to come out of your shell?
You just work at it the same way you would fucking learn how to play guitar,
which is to basically do it every day.
You know,
I sucked at guitar three years ago and now I'm um,
um,
getting halfway decent at guitar because I try to play it every day and the shit
that I still suck at is a shit I don't work at.
So what I would do if I was you is just work at coming out of your shell.
You can try it,
you know,
you go out,
you buy something,
try and make a little Chit Chit chat with the person behind the register if it's
not fucking automated and a,
and give yourself license to suck in the beginning.
That's a big thing about improving shit in your life,
I found is to forgive the fact that in the beginning when you try to talk to
other people,
you're a,
you're not going to be good at it at first.
And,
um,
let me ask you this,
have you ever opened your mouth and said something?
And then an entire room of people turned around and looked at you and said,
what the fuck?
And then they all beat the shit out of you.
I mean,
that was my fear.
That was my fear in high school that that's what was going to happen.
You know what?
It never happened.
And when I finally did open my mouth,
people are like,
hey,
you're funny.
You should have been more like that in high school.
You could have been fucking those fucking cheerleaders,
you know?
So hence,
I have a lot of regret about that period in my lifetime because I wasn't being
myself.
So,
um,
I don't know if you're under age,
you got to go with your mom.
So,
you know,
you gotta go out there just fucking write it out and you know what?
It's going to make you a stronger person to go out,
Dan,
to be a great exercise and coming out of your shell to go there,
be the new kid,
meet some new people.
And,
um,
as far as moving out,
the best advice I can give you is get a can opener and all that little innocuous
bullshit that you take for granted in your mother's house.
Um,
you know,
and then,
I dunno,
don't,
uh,
don't hang around with assholes,
you know,
don't hang out with psychos and by I don't mean psychos like the standing there
with a bloody ax,
but you know,
all those PE people play like fucking mind games with you and you feel them
getting competitive with you.
Those aren't friends,
you know,
are you going,
it can happen like one or two times,
but you address it and if it continues to happen,
dump them because it's just,
you know,
those are the kinds of people that if you start doing well in life,
they actually resent you.
And uh,
it's kind of like that guy before earlier that I was talking about with that
woman kind of,
you know,
saved them a lot of pain by leaving early.
You can do that with friends yourself.
Does that make any sense?
You know,
the second he starts seeing someone's being a Douche,
if your gut is telling you that they are a Douche and there's no reason to be
around them.
But uh,
I hope that helps you out.
I'm kind of rushing through here though,
cause I got to only like eight minutes left here before I got to get on.
Um,
all right,
Bill.
Um,
his last advice when I'm going to read bill,
I've been going out with this girl for,
I love how I'm giving relationship advice yet.
I've never had a successful relationship,
although I like to think this one's a little successful,
don't you Nia?
Who's sneaking around the room?
You find you find this relationship successful?
Oh,
define successful.
We have healthy arguments,
don't we?
Yeah.
Hi.
Wow.
That was hilarious for you went.
Yeah.
And then you're like,
wait,
that didn't sound like a good,
yeah,
we do.
All right.
You know what?
That was right the first time.
Beat it.
Let me finish this.
Oh,
okay.
You didn't have to put that over there.
You just trying to stay in here longer.
All right,
well let's plow ahead here.
Bill.
I been going out with this girl for a little over a year and she's been,
she's beginning to Piss me off.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
He,
you know,
at this question could be for about 9,000 people right now.
She complains about not having any money and never offers to pay when we go out
somewhere.
But when she goes out with their friends to the bar or something,
she spends it like no fucking tomorrow as a man.
I don't mind paying for shit most of the time,
but fucking offer to pay,
you know.
But fucking offered to pay would be a great,
would be great sometime,
but fucking offering to pay.
See,
it's not always my reading.
Sometimes people don't write shit correctly,
but fucking offering to pay would be great sometime.
Um,
I don't want to seem like an ass making the girl pay for Shit,
but give me a fucking break.
Times have changed.
Equality is prevailing.
So why don't you throw some dough like the guys do a,
what should I do to get her to start spending some money on me or at least
fucking offer without me making me out to be the Dick?
Basically tell me what you just told me and take out all the fucks.
That's seriously dude,
that's the secret.
You have to,
you have to,
and I had to do this because I have a temper and I say fuck every other word.
I would literally sit down with a piece of paper and I would write the,
the two or three points that I was trying to make and um,
just to make sure that I,
I didn't,
you know,
that this is what I wanted to say.
And then I would also,
and then I would draw out this happened,
I have a,
how much of a psycho I was,
I had to draw a little smiley face next to it,
which would remind me not to say it with my usual angry east coast tone.
All right,
so what you have to tell her is that basically what you tell me then a big thing
with women,
you've got to tell how it makes you feel when she doesn't offer to pay.
All right?
Yet you have to sit there and listen to her,
you know,
complaining about money yet she doesn't offer to pay and how it makes you feel
when you then see her throwing the money around with their friends and makes you
feel like what?
Like she's treating you see I was going to say like an ATM.
See this is what happens when I will write shit down.
That's very hostile.
He treated me like a fucking ATM.
What?
I'm not good enough to spend fucking money on you fucking whore so you can't go
that route.
You got it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] what the fuck are you eating lately?
Just gassing me out.
You know.
So I am convinced with dogs that there,
there is no like,
uh,
is no toxins built up in them.
They just don't give a shit.
You know,
they got a fucking rip one.
They just do.
Um,
anyways,
that's what you have to do.
You've got to tell out how that makes you feel,
you know,
um,
and just,
I dunno,
you know what the more you do with you,
you're going to learn how to do it.
And it's like keywords that you can use with women that makes their ears perk up
per cup without getting mad at you is basically,
if you say,
it makes me feel like this.
And you used words like,
you know,
I just kind of feel like there's a lack of respect there.
I mean that's,
you gotta go like this way more,
uh,
sort of mature way and not because they're more mature.
So get off your high horse is ladies,
you just have to go that way or else they will fucking turn it around on you.
Okay.
The fact that you're fucking paying for everything,
somehow that point will,
you'll somehow be in the wrong.
And um,
there's two ways to know you're winning an argument with the female is,
uh,
one,
they're trying to pull some fucking Jujitsu,
double reverse two point reversal fucking move on you.
And a lot of times last,
their last ditch suicide bomber fucking mood move is they cry.
All right?
And the thing about is a guy,
if you want to win an argument,
the woman,
okay?
And I'm not just saying win,
but you really want to make your point when you know you're right,
because you're right on this one.
If your version of what's going on is actually going on,
you're fucking right on this one,
okay?
So what you have to do is not lose your cool.
You cannot get,
you don't take the bait and she'll do shit.
She'll bring up shit from your fucking childhood.
She'll bring up,
oh,
and you didn't do the fucking dishes.
She'll do something if you get a dead to rights,
okay?
If you,
if you don't,
if you do,
it all depends on her personality.
If she's a real defensive,
combative person,
you really got to watch out for that breed.
Okay?
Those little terrier fucking women,
what you gotta do is just know that she's going to say all that stuff and that
you,
you got to keep your fucking cool.
And once they start,
you don't have to go name calling or something like that.
That's just,
that's hostile.
They basically,
that's a fucking word I can never remember.
Um,
God dammit,
you know,
uh,
capitulate,
that's a great word too.
If you use that commonly,
it's basically is when you just abandon your,
the,
the argument and you just start,
you don't reverting to like name calling or you abandon your argument and they
start agreeing with you or something like that.
I don't fucking know.
It just sounds great to say it.
But anyways,
um,
you gotta do,
you got it.
You'd write down what you want to say,
say it and just say how you feeling.
Take out all the fucks and if she tries to turn it around on you,
you know,
by bringing,
if she starts bringing up other shit while you do this,
will you do that?
And he don't,
don't allow that.
You know what I mean?
And if she wants to talk about,
you know,
I,
you leave your shoes,
you know,
in the middle of the living room and be like,
okay,
well before we discuss that,
can we,
can we finish discussing this?
You just got to keep steering it back.
It's like fucking law and order.
You've got to cross examine them and I'm telling you,
watch out for that crying bullshit.
All right?
Cause that's a latch diff.
That's their fucking 60 yard field goal or hail Mary pass when they know that
they're going to fucking lose.
And I'm telling you,
they're all there like Meryl Streep.
That's why I'm not blown away by Meryl Streep.
Okay.
You know,
have my girlfriends can fucking act as good as she can at bullshit.
She's a great actress,
just being a Douche.
Um,
so anyways,
there you go.
That's how you do it.
All right?
And that's how you win an argument.
If you're right,
or at least that's how you,
you make your point.
Okay.
And if they wanted to revert to name calling and bring up shift from your
childhood,
just don't take the bait and then what's going to end up happening is they're
just going to be sitting there feeling like a jerk.
And um,
you know,
if they're mature enough then they'll apologize for the name calling and say,
I was actually wrong.
I got defenses,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
But if there's psycho,
they'll actually try to cry their way out of it.
And I'm just know this,
that when an adult is beyond the age of,
uh,
eight,
if you didn't punch them in the face or call them some horrific name,
there's really no reason to be crying.
So if they are crying,
you know,
it's like those fucking commercials here on the radio,
they give you a free car and you don't have to give him any money till like
September of 2015.
It,
it's,
it,
it sounds like bullshit,
doesn't it?
It has to be somehow you're getting fucked.
And that's the same way it is.
Like most of the times when women are crying.
All right.
Okay,
let's get on to some questions here.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
I gave this guy shit talking about how,
you know,
games weren't invented in England.
What the fuck is he talking about?
And here's somebody actually was trying to tell me that I was wrong on that one.
Said I would thought ever respond to your comments about,
uh,
what sports did the English had invent.
Um,
I think the English did invent baseball.
It was called rounders,
like in the 17 or 18 hundreds and it was played mostly by girls.
Not Kidding.
Look it up.
I actually looked it up.
Um,
and it seems like,
yeah,
there is a game called rounders,
but that's one of those,
you know,
that's like one of those things like somebody invents a guitar and then they
take credit for Jimi Hendrix,
you know,
I dunno.
Maybe I'm,
then I'm exaggerating.
Um,
I just don't understand why.
If there is a game like baseball in England,
why you would play cricket,
you know,
and don't they where a bunch of pads,
those big catcher pads don't,
they wear that shit and he was just plow ahead.
Um,
besides what you mentioned on the podcast,
they also invented,
he wrote Bob's sleigh.
Is that Bob sledding,
tennis,
Ping Pong table tennis.
Golf in badminton.
Well,
if you want to take credit for those fucking sissy games,
go for it.
Bad mitten.
Really Ping Pong.
I like how you keep inventing games that then other people dominate golf.
Tiger Woods.
Thank you.
Ping Pong.
China.
You lose that one.
Tennis was the last saving from England,
England.
One to fucking Wimbleton never.
You got to go back to when only white people were allowed to play and they were
a little fucking a cutoff slacks.
No,
actually they work.
they wore slacks.
That's right.
There were full length pants and they had wooden rackets that the later use to
hit a woman over the head with sick fucking have a girlfriend,
um,
bad mitten who plays badminton.
Members of your royal family.
All right.
Um,
I said I wasn't going to be a jerk,
but I,
and I ended up being a jerk.
Let's close out here with the questions.
Uh,
Bill,
I recently started,
you know what?
It's one,
all three.
What the fuck am I doing?
I got to get to the questions next week.
I gave out a lot of vices week.
No,
always.
No.
My disclaimer,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I can do is a judge,
you know,
go from my own life here.
How I've handled some shit as the psycho that I am.
All right.
Ah,
Shit.
That was 53 minutes,
so I didn't even do a short one.
Hope you guys all have a good week and please come out and check me out,
uh,
over the next couple of months while I get ready for my special,
I'm in a Addison at the Improv this weekend.
I'm at the stress factory in New Jersey next weekend and the weekend after that,
I'm at the Improv in Pittsburgh.
I'm petting my dog with my foot.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com B.
U R,
R for all of my other,
uh,
all my other dates are all the information on the dates that I mentioned.
God bless all.
Yes.
Have a great day.
Ooh,
Gotcha.
Ooh.